What happens to highly contaminated water
when it is placed in SCP-914, the Clockworks?
Dr. Ira selected one pint of highly contaminated
water for experimentation.
It was placed into the machine on the setting
"Fine," and this was the resulting output:
A balloon-like instance resembling a Tardigrade.
It was entirely translucent, and able to float
around the room.
Dr. Ira then noted, “It wouldd appear that
all of the tissue making this thing up is
extremely loosely samples of bacteria in the
initial pint of water, in addition to small
water molecule chains holding it together.
Apologies for the rule bending here, I'd honestly
completely forgotten about microscopic beings
in context of this thing.”